[S01] 想象一下这个场景啊
[S01] 你正盯着屏幕看着一张
[S01] 嗯绝对是全网最低价的最后一张特价机票
[S02] 哇那种让人心跳加速的时刻
[S01] 对吧
[S01] 然后你果断点击购买
[S01] 看着那个加载的圈圈转了两秒
[S01] 你的信用卡甚至
[S01] 甚至都已经收到了扣款短信了
[S02] 结果呢
[S01] 结果屏幕上弹出一行冷冰冰的红字
[S01] 写着抱歉该票已售罄
[S02] 你这时候肯定会拍着桌子想到底是谁偷了我的票
[S01] 哈哈这太真实了
[S01] 在物理世界里你拿起了货架上的最后一块巧克力
[S01] 那它就是你的非常确定
[S02] 没错但是在数字世界里
[S02] 当你按下按钮的那一刻
[S02] 你其实是一脚踏进了
[S02] 呃分布式系统里最深邃也最容易让人抓狂的泥潭
[S01] 那个泥潭
[S02] 对这个泥潭的核心就是机器之间到底如何对现实达成一致
[S01] 所以这也是我们今天这次深度探讨的任务
[S01] 我们要彻底剖析软件工程领域的绝对经典
[S01] 就是那本《设计数据密集型应用》的第十章
[S02] 嗯这张可以说是非常硬核了
[S01] 极其硬核
[S01] 我们要拨开那些晦涩的底层架构外衣
[S01] 但你弄懂为什么特价机票会凭空消失
[S01] 社交网络为什么会在你
[S01] 呃改了隐私设置之后依然泄露你的照片
[S02] 还有就是系统在充满断网宕机这些混乱的网络世界里
[S02] 究竟是怎么达成所谓的共识的
[S01] 对那让我们直接切入那个令人崩溃的机票问题吧
[S01] 系统之所以会出bug之所以会骗你根本原因在于我们需要复制数据对吧
[S02] 没错就是复制
[S02] 因为
[S02] 呃为了防止一台server突然断电导致所有航班信息灰飞烟灭
[S02] 系统就必须把数据备份到位于不同城市的几台机器上
[S01] 但这立刻就引出了一个巨大的悖论呢
[S01] 就是数据的副本越多他们之间就越容易打架
[S01] 状态就越难同步
[S02] 这就引出了整个分布式世界里最苛刻的一项标准了
[S02] 也就是线性一致性
[S01] 线性一致性或者有时也被叫做强一致性
[S02] 对它的本质其实就是让一个由成百上千台机器组成的庞大系统
[S02] 对外表现的好像
[S02] 好像它绝对只有一份数据副本
[S02] 而且所有的操作都必须是原子的
[S01] 就是一种绝对的新鲜度保证对吧
[S01] 一旦某个客户端成功写入了新数据
[S01] 系统就必须保证之后任何来读取数据的客户端都只能看到这个最新值
[S02] 绝不能看到历史遗留的旧数据
[S01] 资料里有一个关于体育比分的例子我觉得非常生动
[S01] 就是假设有两个球迷阿利亚和Bryce他们坐在同一个房间里各自刷着手机
[S02] 嗯看同一场比赛
[S01] 对比赛一结束
[S01] 阿利亚的手机先刷新了
[S01] 他看到了最终的获胜比分兴奋的大声欢呼
[S02] Bryce听到欢呼之后赶紧下拉刷新自己的屏幕
[S01] 结果呢
[S01] 他的手机连到了一个数据稍微滞后的副本服务器
[S01] 屏幕上竟然显示比赛还在进行中
[S02] 哇这对Bryce来说完全是一场时光倒流啊
[S01] 确实是时光倒流
[S01] 他在现实的三维世界里明明已经听到了最新结果
[S01] 但在数字世界里却看到了过去
[S01] 这就是典型的呃违反了线性一致性
[S02] 这种感觉就像是所有人都盯着讲台上同一块黑板
[S02] 一旦老师擦掉旧答案写下了新答案
[S02] 那后面任何抬头看黑板的学生绝不可能再看到旧的自己
[S01] 这个比喻很恰当
[S02] 所以如果要防止我们刚才说的特价机票被超卖
[S02] 系统也必须盯着同一块黑板
[S02] 依靠一种叫比较并设置的操作
[S02] 英文简称CAS
[S01] 对CAS
[S01] 系统会先看一眼黑板
[S01] 诶这个座位还是空的吗
[S01] 只有答案为是它才会写上你的名字
[S02] 如果两个用户同时抢
[S02] 稍微慢了一毫秒的那个系统在比较那一步就会发现座位已经不空了
[S02] 从而拒绝写入
[S01] 是的但你要知道
[S01] 只有在严格的线性一致性下
[S01] 这种比较并设置才能真正发挥真正作用
[S01] 处理好唯一性约束
[S01] 否则的话
[S02] 否则两个不同的副本可能同时认为座位是空的
[S01] 没错然后导致你们俩拿着同一张票去登机
[S02] 诶等一下
[S02] 既然复制数据会引发副本打架
[S02] 副本之间同步还要花费大量时间
[S02] 为什么我们不干脆
[S02] 就是退回去呢
[S01] 退回去你的意思是
[S02] 我们就花重金买一台配置极其奢华超级强大的服务器来搞定所有事
[S02] 不见任何副本
[S02] 这样不就从物理上绝对保证线性一致性了吗
[S01] 啊这可是会遭遇分布式系统的致命伤的
[S01] 也就是单点故障
[S01] 你想想看如果整座摩天大楼只有一根承重柱
[S01] 无论这根柱子用多么坚固的钛合金打造
[S02] 一旦它因为地震断裂整栋楼就会瞬间倒塌
[S02] 没错
[S02] 在现实的机房里
[S02] 光缆被挖掘机挖断
[S02] 硬盘老化报废啊
[S02] 甚至整个街区停电
[S02] 这些可不是可能会发生的意外
[S01] 这是每天都在上演的日常
[S02] 对啊
[S02] 单一服务器确实能保证一致性
[S02] 但它一旦宕机你的整个服务就彻底瘫痪了
[S02] 用户根本连APP都打不开
[S01] 那么这就顺理成章的来到了工程师们最头疼的痛点
[S01] 我们必须要有多个副本但同时又想要线性一致性的完美体验
[S01] 可是如果北京机房和上海机房之间的光缆突然断了
[S01] 发生了所谓的网络分区
[S01] 这时候系统该怎么办
[S02] 这是一个非常残酷的物理现实
[S02] 当网络发生断裂时
[S02] 如果你死磕系统必须是线性一致的
[S02] 那么对于那些连不上主节点的副本来说
[S02] 他们只有两个选择
[S01] 哪两个
[S02] 要么无限期的等在网络恢复
[S02] 卡在那里转圈圈
[S02] 要么直接给用户弹出一个报错页面
[S02] 无论选哪个从用户的角度看系统都变得不可用了
[S01] 听到这里很多稍微懂一点技术的人可能会想到那个著名的CAP定理
[S01] 也就是一致性可用性分区容错性三者只能选其二
[S02] 经常听到对吧
[S01] 太经常了
[S01] 在无数的技术会议上工程师们总是摸着下巴深沉的讨论哎呀在这个项目里我们要选CP架构还是AP架构呢
[S01] 但我看资料里的观点非常犀利啊
[S01] 他直接说整个科技界流行了二十年的口头禅其实是个伪命题
[S02] 确实如此
[S02] CAP定理在现代系统设计中
[S02] 呃其实几乎没有实际实到价值
[S02] 因为网络分区也就是那个P
[S02] 它是一种客观发生的物理故障
[S02] 你不能跟物理定律讨价还价说我今天不想要网络断裂
[S01] 哈哈物理定律可不听你的
[S02] 对所以你根本没有三个选项去挑两个
[S02] 真正的抉择永远只有一个
[S02] 当网络客观上断开时
[S02] 你是要坚持数据的绝对一致宁愿报错或卡住
[S02] 还是要保证服务的可用性宁愿返回旧数据
[S01] 哇所以工程师们争论了这么多年其实是把前提搞错了
[S01] 更有意思的是资料里还揭示了一个极多反直觉的事实
[S02] 嗯你说的是单机电脑那个
[S01] 对
[S01] 我们一直以为线性一致性只是横跨两地的网络系统里的难题
[S01] 但其实就在你桌上的这台单机电脑里
[S01] 在现代多核CPU的不同核心之间默认也是没有线性一致性的
[S02] 没错
[S02] 在单台电脑内部我们显然不担心光缆被挖断的问题
[S02] CPU主动放弃线性一致性的原因只有一个
[S02] 那就是为了极致的性能
[S01] 这个性能差距到底有多大
[S02] 极其巨大
[S02] 如果CPU每次读写数据都要取主内存
[S02] 也就是RAM里核对最新状态
[S02] 一次大约需要一百纳秒
[S01] 听起来也挺快的呀
[S02] 但如果它直接读取自己核心旁边的L一缓存
[S02] 只需要一纳秒
[S02] 这可是一百倍的速溶差距
[S01] 我的天一百倍
[S02] 如果强制要求所有CPU核心保持线性一致
[S02] 每一次计算都要跨越这一百倍的延时
[S02] 你的现代电脑会卡的呃连十几年前的网页都打不开
[S02] 所以不管是网络传输还是芯片内部
[S02] 追求线性一致性都会带来极高的延迟代价
[S01] 既然完美的绝对一致性代价极其高昂又慢又容易导致系统不可用
[S01] 那系统能不能退而求其次不强求大家同时看到一样的画面
[S01] 而是仅仅通过给每个操作打时间戳来排个先后顺序呢
[S01] 这就好像给去银行办事的人发排队号码牌
[S02] 单纯依赖墙上的物理时钟是非常危险的
[S02] 因为每台机器的时钟走得快慢不一很容易导致顺序错乱
[S02] 所以工程师发明了逻辑时钟
[S01] 逻辑时钟它不看物理时间吗
[S02] 对它不看物理时间
[S02] 只看事件的因果关系
[S02] 也就是谁在谁之后发生
[S02] 但依变使用了逻辑时钟
[S02] 系统依然隐藏着一个巨大的陷阱
[S02] 跨通道时序依赖的噩梦
[S01] 资料里的这个例子简直让人后背发凉
[S01] 想象一个场景
[S01] 用户A在社交网络上先进行了一次操作
[S01] 把自己的账户权限设置为私密
[S01] 紧接着他放心的上传了一张非常尴尬的私人照片
[S01] 在他的视角里这完全没问题对吧
[S02] 对在用户的视角是完美的
[S02] 但在系统底层
[S02] 负责管理账户权限的数据库
[S02] 和负责存储照片的数据库是两个独立的子系统
[S01] 然后呢
[S02] 由于网络波动照片数据库很快处理完毕了
[S02] 并分配到了一个时间戳
[S02] 但权限更新的请求却在网络里卡顿了一下
[S02] 拿到了一个稍微靠后的时间戳
[S01] 等等你的意思是如果照片拿到的时间戳比权限更新的时间戳还要早
[S01] 那在系统的全局视角下有那么极其短暂的一两秒钟
[S01] 系统会认为这张照片是在账户处于公开状态时上传的
[S02] 就会把这张本该私密的尴尬照片直接展示给他
[S01] 哇这就好像我先发了一封平信去邮局
[S01] 要求修改我的查阅权限
[S01] 紧接着我又发了一封加急电报传真了一张照片过去
[S02] 嗯
[S01] 虽然我是严格按顺序发出的
[S01] 但系统收到电报的时候甚至都不知道那封平信的存在
[S01] 那么之前提到的那种非常聪明的算法
[S01] 比如兰破特逻辑时钟
[S01] 它把计数器和节点ID结合起来不是号称能记录因果关系吗
[S01] 为什么它救不了这张照片
[S02] 因为兰破的时钟的工作原理是节点在每次互相通信时都会带着自己的计数器
[S02] 然后大家取最大值加一
[S02] 比如节点A告诉节点B我的计数是五
[S02] B完了是三现在他就知道哦整个世界至少已经到了五
[S02] 那我接下来的操作就是六
[S01] 听起来很完美啊大家互相通气通过这种口口相传的方式来同步时间线就不会乱了
[S02] 致命的盲区就在这里
[S02] 节点之间必须有直接的通信才能建立因果关系
[S02] 在刚才的照片例子里
[S02] 权限数据库和照片数据库在那个瞬间并没有直接交流彼此的计数器
[S01] 啊他们只是各自接受了用户的指令
[S02] 没错因为缺乏内部沟通
[S02] 兰破的时钟就无法发现这两个事件的先后顺序
[S02] 如果你想要给全宇宙所有事件排出一个绝对的先后顺序
[S02] 即使他们之间从未通信
[S02] 你就必须需要有一个拥有上帝视角的完美的全局ID生成器
[S01] 于是我们绕了一大圈终于碰到了那堵终极的墙
[S01] 无论是想要一个不会出错的全局ID生成器
[S01] 还是想要我们最开始买机票时那个能防止超卖的CAS操作
[S01] 所有问题的尽头都卡在同一个瓶颈上
[S02] 就是当系统里的节点随时可能崩溃失联的时候
[S02] 大家到底如何对某一个决定达成绝对的不可推翻的一致
[S01] 这就是分布式系统里的圣杯共识
[S02] 共识
[S02] 它要求满足四个极其苛刻的属性
[S02] 第一一致同意
[S02] 也就是所有不可崩溃的节点必须决定同一个值
[S02] 第二完整性决定了就绝不能反悔
[S01] 第三是有效性
[S01] 决定的值必须是有人提议的
[S02] 对然后最难的是第四个终止促性
[S02] 意思是系统必须取得进展
[S02] 不能因为某个节点崩溃了大家就无限期的死等下去
[S01] 资料里还提到一个在理论上极其惊人的等价性
[S01] 我们前面提到的机票CIC操作单值共识
[S01] 全序广播也就是让所有节点按完全相同的绝对顺序写入日志
[S01] 甚至跨越多个数据库的原子事物提交
[S02] 嗯这些看似不同的概念
[S01] 对这些在普通程序员眼里看起来完全不搭边的技术
[S01] 在数学和逻辑层面竟然是完全等价的
[S02] 是的只要你解开了其中一个问题
[S02] 就等于拿到了解开所有问题的万能钥匙
[S02] 就就好比你发现冰水和水蒸气本质上都是H2O
[S02] 如果你有了一个完美的共识算法
[S02] 你就能实现全序广播
[S02] 有了全序广播你就能做原子事物
[S02] 它们本质上是同一个技术幽灵的不同化身
[S01] 哇但我也看到了一个让人绝望的定理
[S01] 叫做FLP不可能性定理
[S01] 这个定理在数学上严格证明了在完全异步的系统里
[S01] 只要存在哪怕一个节点崩溃的风险
[S01] 共识算法就不可能总是满足刚才说的终止属性
[S02] 系统早晚有一天会永远卡死
[S01] 对啊那既然理论上已经宣判了死刑
[S01] 我们每天用的跨国银行转账移动支付
[S01] 难道都是建立在一个随时会崩溃的理论漏洞上的吗
[S02] 哈哈这就展示了理论模型与现实工程的奇妙温差了
[S02] FLP定理在数学上确实是无懈可击的
[S02] 但它的前提是假设系统没有物理时钟
[S02] 不能使用超时机制
[S01] 哦所以现实中我们怎么做
[S02] 在现实的工程中我们不需要那么纯粹的数学完美
[S02] 我们通过引入超时机制
[S02] 和随机数非常巧妙的绕过了这个不可能定理
[S01] 也就是说我们给系统设定一个耐心限度
[S01] 如果主节点五秒钟没反应我们就当它已经死了立刻开启新一轮选举继续往前走
[S02] 没错在实际应用中
[S02] 比如RAFT或者PAXOS这样的共识算法
[S02] 通常使用两轮投票机制
[S02] 系统会划分出不同的纪元
[S02] 第一轮投票大家选一个带着新纪元标号的主节点
[S02] 第二轮大家对这个主节点提议的数据进行投票
[S01] 这里面最核心的魔法是不是在于法定票数
[S01] quorum的设置
[S01] 通常是要求过半数的节点同意
[S02] 没错过半数
[S01] 可是过半数怎么能防止脑裂呢
[S01] 也就是系统突然分裂成两派
[S01] 有两个主节点同时发号施令的情况
[S02] 我们可以用一个简单的抽屉原理来解释
[S02] 假设你的系统有五个节点
[S02] 选出一个主节点需要至少三票
[S02] 而主节点要把机票卖给你的决定写进系统
[S02] 也需要至少三个节点同意
[S02] 五个节点里拿两个三出来
[S02] 数学上必然至少有一个节点是重叠的
[S01] 啊我明白了
[S01] 这个重叠的节点就是系统的记忆
[S01] 因为它刚刚在第一轮给真正的主节点投过票
[S01] 所以如果这时候网络卡顿
[S01] 跑出来一个旧的僵尸主节点想要写入数据
[S01] 这个重叠的节点就会说等等
[S01] 我已经进入新纪元了我拒绝你的旧指令
[S01] 这就从物理上绝对掐断了两个主节点同时操作的可能
[S02] 完全正确
[S02] 这就是通过两轮重叠的多数派投票
[S02] 在混乱的网络中强制锁死唯一事实的机制
[S01] 听起来真是巧夺天工的逻辑艺术
[S01] 但是听你讲完这些纪元呐多数派投票啊
[S01] 防止脑裂的边界条件
[S01] 我觉得如果是让我作为一个普通的软件工程师
[S01] 要在自己的APP里从头写一套这种共识算法
[S01] 我大概率会漏掉某个极其罕见的边界条件
[S02] 然后在一个深夜把用户的数据全部弄掉
[S01] 绝对会
[S02] 哈哈你并不孤单
[S02] 几乎所有的资深工程师都有同样的恐惧
[S02] 自己手写共识算法就像是在雷区里蒙眼狂奔
[S02] 稍有不慎比如网络重发导致的状态乱序
[S02] 就会造成灾难性的数据损害
[S01] 所以在现实中开发者的选择是通通外包
[S02] 对外包
[S02] 这就来到了我们要拆解的最后一部分协调服务
[S02] 比如大名鼎鼎的Zookeeper或者ETCD
[S02] 很多开发者第一次看到Zookeeper的界面
[S02] 会觉得它就是个简单的键值对数据库
[S01] 它外表看起来确实像个简单的键值存储
[S01] 但资料里说你绝对不能把大量的应用数据塞进里面
[S02] 千万别它的核心作用是把刚才说的极其复杂容易出错的共识算法深埋在自己内部
[S02] 然后对外提供傻瓜式的容错工具
[S02] 比如分室锁租约心跳故障检测以及一种叫防护令牌的东西
[S01] 防护令牌这是干什么用的
[S02] 刚才你提到如果有旧的僵尸主节点跑出来捣乱怎么办对吧
[S02] Zookeeper在发放锁的时候会顺便发一个单调递增的令牌数字
[S02] 比如三十三
[S01] 嗯
[S02] 当拿到令牌的主节点去数据写数据时
[S02] 数据会记录下三十三
[S02] 如果之后那个因为断网卡住的僵尸主节点醒了
[S02] 拿着旧令牌三十二试图去写数据
[S02] 存储系统一对比发现三十二小于三十三就会直接把僵尸节点踢出去
[S01] 哇这就好像是公证处发出的带有防伪标号的证书
[S01] 而且你肯定不会把你每天买咖啡的账单都拿去公证处盖章啊
[S01] 你只会在需要决定这套房子到底归谁的时候
[S01] 也就是需要获取一把全网唯一的锁时才会去找Zookeeper
[S02] 没错这其实是一种关注点分离
[S02] 把成千上万台服务器的共识问题剥离出来交给后台三到五个精锐节点组成的公证处专门处理
[S02] 这不仅安全而且极大地降低了网络开销
[S01] 而普通的业务数据库就可以放心的去处理海量数据
[S01] 把最棘手的协调员数据交给协调服务
[S01] 这正是现代庞大系统能够稳定运转的设计哲学呀
[S02] 是的
[S01] 太精彩了
[S01] 让我们来快速回顾一下今天这场脑力激荡的核心收获
[S01] 我们一起弄懂了线性一致性这个能让分布式系统表现的像单机一样简单的强大幻想
[S02] 我们还打破了CAP定理三选二的迷思
[S02] 认清了在网络分区下放弃完美一致性往往是无可奈何的唯一选择
[S01] 没错我们还了解了CPU缓存为了性能而主动放弃一致性的现实
[S01] 探讨了逻辑时钟如何捕捉因果却依然受限于跨通道的通信盲区
[S02] 最后我们揭开了共识这个系统圣杯的真面目
[S02] 看到了工程师们如何用重叠投票的数学魔法
[S02] 以及外包给Zookeeper这样的协调服务在混沌中建立起数字世界的秩序
[S01] 每一次当你顺畅的买到最后一张特价机票时
[S01] 背后有无数个节点在光速进行着妥协投票与权衡
[S01] 在结束今天这期节目之前我想抛出一个由资料延伸出来的极其挑衅的终极问题
[S02] 哦什么问题
[S01] 一百多年前爱因斯坦的相对论向物理学界证明了
[S01] 宇宙中根本不存在绝对的全局的时间
[S01] 每个观察者的时间都是相对的
[S01] 取悦于他们的参考系
[S01] 既然宇宙本身都是相对的
[S01] 那我们在分布式系统中花费如此巨大的算力
[S01] 设计极其复杂的共识算法
[S01] 拼了命的想要维持一个线性一致性的绝对全局视角
[S01] 我们是不是在逆抗宇宙本身的物理法则
[S02] 哇把分布式系统的时间线与相对论的时空观联系起来
[S02] 这确实是对架构本质最深刻的叩问了
[S01] 也许在未来的某一天
[S01] 软件架构会彻底放弃让所有节点达成绝对一致的执念
[S01] 全面拥抱一个永远最终一致充满相对论色彩的数字世界
[S01] 你觉得呢
[S02] 这绝对是个值得深思的方向
[S01] 感谢你今天收听我们的硬核拆解
[S01] 下次当你看着屏幕上转圈圈最后特价机票消失的时候
[S01] 先别急着砸手机
[S01] 深吸一口气告诉自己那只是因为宇宙还没有对你的订单达成共识
[S01] 我们下次再见